[D. Evans] Now let's get started running code in the Python interpreter.
For this class you don't need to install any new software.
You can run Python right in your web browser.
You should see something like this in your web browser once the video stops.
There are 2 parts to this.
There's the environment where you can edit code.
So let's type code to print 3.
Print is a Python command that prints something out.
And then after the print we can have any expression we want that is valid Python,
and we'll talk more about what expressions are in Python.
Now we're just going to print the number 3.
And when we click Run, it will run this code and show us the result down here.
And the result of printing 3, we see the output 3.
We can do more interesting things.
We can print an arithmetic expression.
I've got 1+1.
Now we run this. We see both outputs.
First we printed 3. We see this 3 here.
Then we printed 1+1. We see the result of 1+1 is 2.
We can write this more clearly by having spaces.
We can have spaces between the parts of our expression,
so we can have 1 + 1 with spaces between there.
That's a little easier to read.
When we run that we see the same result. The result is still 2.
And we can make more and more complex expressions.
Let's print the result of 52 * 3 + 12 * 9.
This will print out the result of multiplying 52 * 3
and adding that to multiplying 12 * 9.
And we get 264.
You can check that yourself to see that Python got the right answer.
We can use parentheses to group expressions.
If we use parentheses, we can do what we did before
but putting parentheses around grouping the multiplications
and grouping the other multiplication.
And when we run this we see the same result.
Without the parentheses that means the same thing as we had
when we add the parentheses like this.
If we put the parentheses in different places, it means something different.
Now what it means is 52 times the result of adding 3 + 12, which is 15, times 9.
And so we get the result 7020.
We can combine any expressions that we want like this.
For example, if we wanted to compute the number of seconds in a year,
we could compose many multiplications.
So we'll multiply 365 days times 24 hours in a day times 60 minutes in an hour
times 60 seconds in a minute.
We can do all those multiplications together, and we get this result,
which is about 31½ million seconds in a year.
So now it's time for your first programming quiz.
You've seen enough to be able to write a Python program.
Your goal is to write a Python program that prints out the number of minutes there are
in 7 weeks, which is the amount of time we have for this course.
You'll do that by entering your code in here,
and then you can try different things.
You can try running the code, see the result,
and then when you've got an answer, you can click to submit that answer
and see if it's correct.
[First Programming Quiz!]
[Write a Python program that prints out the number of minutes in seven weeks.]